we're going to head over to victoria
saha we sent her out in the elements she
is live look at this she is live near
the foothills of kyle canyon the snow
flurries still continue but it's really
the winds that seem to be the big issue
there right victoria
oh yeah it's super windy which makes it
a little really cold i'm all bundled up
here we're at the 4 000 level here at
kyle canyon but there's still some light
flurries but again it's the wind that's
giving us some issues but up ahead on
the road when you go up to 5 000 feet
there's snow and of course here in las
vegas snow excites a lot of folks we've
been seeing some cars going up the
mountain but there are restrictions now
you need to have chains on your tires
four-wheel drive or snow tires otherwise
you cannot go up there the flashers were
growing off when my photog and i were
trying to drive up there of course we
couldn't go any further so we had to
come back down there are also some road
closures about 20 miles from us they're
at lee canyon their state route 156 is
closed so if you are planning on going
up there you can't because it is closed
of course like you mentioned ted they've
got a lot of snow seven inches quite a
big deal right i'm going to send it over
to you guys back at the studio
victoria stay safe and warm out there be
sure to follow 8 news now anytime
weather changes happen in our valley our
weather team has been voted most
accurate seven years in a row for a
reason